so let's find out more about the
opportunities for tech companies going
public these days robert kuhn joins us
now he's from the deutsche acting
institute that is an association of
german exchange listed stock
corporations and other companies and
institutions with an interest in the
capital market good to have you here
with us and of course you know about
facebook and twitter and more and more
tech companies going public these days
shares are rising which is a good thing
but
where are the german tech firms
well stock performance and ipo
activities are clearly linked together
after the financial crisis we didn't saw
any ipo activity as share prices fell
and so
but in the meantime
the stock market's recovered
tax
performs on an all-time high
therefore we hope that also tech
companies will reach the capital market
and raise funds on
via an ipo okay
when you say the stock market recovered
and the taxes well because we can see
just now when we look at twitter's ipo
last week it was quite interesting it
was a great uh debut there it started
with huge games ending the first trading
day at uh 45
10 cents a share that's way above the
initial share price of 26
how do you explain this success
especially with something like twitter
which uh so far hasn't turned a profit
yet
it's difficult to explain but i think
it's the whole sentiment on the markets
but
this is this is a short-term perspective
and so we have to wait and see how
twitter is able to translate this huge
number of users into profits and then we
will see if
the
the investment is really a success
what if it isn't what if twitter and
facebook uh which has recovered uh since
its ipo which back then was a disaster
what if all these social media and tech
firms actually are nothing but the start
of a new bubble
well i don't think so but
investors have to be aware that they
invest in firms which face a very market
environment which is rapidly changing
and
which is
which is a great competition in the
market and so they have to invest only a
small
part of their investments into shares of
these companies to do not
face too big losses so i mean there's
always risk involved in in what way does
uh do german shareholders perhaps differ
from u.s shareholders is there a
different mentality yes i think
especially retail investors are more
risk averse than the
u.s counterparties
but
we hope that
many or more and more retail investors
will get on the share on the stock
markets because shares are rising at the
moment
because it's a good opportunity to
make
for themselves for the pension systems
okay and so on okay and they need it is
mr specs a good opportunity what's your
advice for a company like that
well mr specks has a very good growth
story
but
this is a very a little bit risky and
they are not well established on the
market and we have to wait and see if
they
can make profits in future as well okay
okay
thank you very much for joining us today